and Vincent troch has been magnificent at
the dot as well as the Rangers have totally
flipped that script de har with a long shot
from the point that's got it away by quick
almost McDavid dry side ales their power play
crushes it CC a sof wrist jop easy stick save
for quick MoGo the first two it at the half
wall plays it back to nurse that shot easily
got it away with the stick Again by Jonathan
Quick put behind the net by McLoud sck P check
for foxy clears that chance away Json with room
with the drive the first test of Skinner and he
surrenders no rebound to Spring the Rangers
and then he just missed the nck here's aanad
going back door prder to aanad out in front
to Wheeler on that save the rebound cars into
the left wing corner and Zan ja tried to track it
there Nurse will settle things down for Edmonson
DeAndre Miller tape to tape zanette nify across
the line rink wide hoping for CER he'll put it
behind the net zaban a one touch back door scar
wheeler what a play by Ma zabad you cannot one
touch a pass prettier than that and wher deposits
it for an early Ranger lead playing with krider
and saan Jad Bob you're right here watch this
play by Zan Jad behind the net the rim comes
around he angles his stick here he knows wheeler
here and he leaves it right on the tape E Holmes
going one way Skinner can't get over to the post
cuz he thinks zad's got the to Guston leaves from
Edy panan on the Move wrist shot save made by
Skinner through a traffic where's the rebound
stabed into the blue paint and now it's cleared
Schneider in the first period we'll see if that
Trend continues here is Fox to panan to set up
the power play panan into the bumper it's across
to Z down to the drrive paner shoots and scores
but Skinner lost his helmet the goal waved off
as the zaban Jad onetime injured Skinner and
the hazards of playing goals to Skinner gets
across this one hits him right on top of the mask
and it knocks It Off it's the straps are you can
see he he just kind of shakes his head and it
falls open saan Jad in the corner saucers to
paner down low crder back door save made by
Skinner he robs zaban jet they got one here
zaban jet has the puck leap up on him a little
bit a saucer pass up in the air and back the
other way comes Fogle Fogle Moves In C one save
made by quick as he robbed Conor brown two goal
lead the Oilers get the best chance it's Conor
Brown short-handed Jonathan Quick goes right
to left spreads out to make the save ni MC David
his frustrating night continues but he's got the
puck a pass for Bard to dve glove save made by
quick very of 90 plus from Evan Bard the only
goenda that down low forand save made by
quick he rob hman right period this was
an incredibly dangerous one Zack Heyman from
right on top of the crease can't move the puck
nen Hopkins recovers buard across McDavid in
the slot save made by quick sprawling to Rob
dry cidal lingren clears him out of there and
then McDavid will find dry cidal who scores so
much from this low circle quick gets all the way
across to make the save and keep the game game
one nothing Z bage at across the line couldn't
control taken back by Conor McDavid down the
right wing boards centering pass held up echo
on the doorstep score hman to the backand RS
it and we are [Applause] [Music] [Applause]
tied Zack heyman's 19th of the Year Rangers
having to back up and of that is as he drives
in the zone it backs up not just kandre Mill
who does a pretty nice job here staying up on
him but Jacob trouba is deep and as he's deep
that puck slides across to Matias eolm EOL makes
a sweet little pass to Zack Heyman and there he
is on top of the blue paint posted in and the
Oilers he's probably able to poke it away but
he's trying to play two players at once it's
a tough decision to make off the draw score of
Ander Kane found the Loose Change he beats
quick and just like that Edmonton has the
lead and a shot that's deflected as quick can't
handle the rebound the puck comes out brayen
Schneider's stick watch right here is going
to hit kanes that changes the shot direction
and speed and it goes right through Jonathan
Quick and in stunning fashion the Oilers a
minute and 10 apart lead 21 out lets lindr pan
with a reach turned back to McLoud dropped off
Fogle shoots SC Warren Fogle picks the corner
and it's a two goal Edmonton lead here in the
third said a little bit earlier as much
as this is about Conor McDavid it would
be nice if somebody from the bottom half of
the lineup scored Evander Kan who's playing
on a third line scored a little earlier Warren
Fogle who comes into the game with one goal in
his last 24 beats Jonathan Quick Ryan McLoud at
a couple of goals last night the rebound played
by panan back to the point and losing his balance
was keyandre Miller it's a two-on-one Fogle shoot
sa it made by quick the rebound on the doorstep
SC McLoud puts in the loose Puck and it's a 41
Edmonton [Applause] lead oh it might be less
of a stressor for the Oilers coaches in four
goals in 10 minutes Warren forgal shot is stopped
and now it bounces around fle stays with it and
mccloud's got his third in two games as this
line with Leon dry cidal is connected here in
the third period a couple of times first fogal
now McLoud stunting 41 Oilers against a ranger
team that does not give up very much time running
out on the Rangers 35 seconds to go on the Power
Play Bouncing Puck for the moment it eluded
Panera now he has it back down low One Touch
into the blue paint by cder a Scramble for it
score it looked like Saban Jad got the final
chove to get it across the line and the Rangers
do connect on the power play it's a two-goal lead
with 48 to go ends up in the go Cree crder is
in front of the that he def Flex it out front
and laier is going to pitch at it first
and zaban gets it before St Skinner can
get a handle on it little tip from krider
laier is stopped in the paint and the puck
is just sitting there and before anyone can
get hoping for kie swept ahead by nurse long
shot save made by Skinner again and the
rebound cleared by nurse 8 seconds to go
it carams in the far corner and the Edmonton
Oilers with a shot on net that's going to go
in as the buzzer sounds but it's academic
the Rangers score a window dressing goal
but this is going to be a road win for the
Edmonton Oilers this will give us the best
look now that looks like it's going to count I get
yep that looks like it's going to count it's going
to be no bother except to the final score and
some people thought that they were going to be
happy and are suddenly sad but that officially
ends it Edmonton wins it 43 here at the Garden